there's a documentary called behind the
curve in which a group of people who
think the Earth is flat decided to test
their hypothesis they spend something
like 20 grand on a laser gyroscope and
they run some tests and lo and behold
they learn that the Earth contrary to
their assumptions is in fact round it
turns out their response to that was
exactly what you'd expect at first they
didn't want to believe it they started
rationalizing away the experiment we
were taken aback by that one of the men
said he added we obviously were not
willing to accept that now that
documentary came out a few years ago it
was an interesting look at human
psychology and how people respond when
their own actions debunk their whole
world viw and I mean literally their
worldview in the case of the flat
earthers it's not an easy thing to
experience you know it's one thing for
someone else to prove you wrong that's
difficult enough it's something else
entirely to disprove your own ideology
and to reveal how bankrupt and
nonsensical it is now it's easy to point
and laugh at flat earthers but this is a
phenomenon that we are seeing more often
these days in fact it's been playing out
for the whole country over the past few
weeks as proponents of the diversity
equity and inclusion or Dei have
witnessed the complete implosion of the
president of Harvard University Claudine
gay now this is a woman who par
personifies everything Dei stands for
she came from an extremely wealthy
background her family runs the the
largest concrete plant in Haiti she
became the first black president of
Harvard University despite publishing
only a handful of academic pap papers
and she did it all based on three
factors her skin color her gender and
her willingness to smear and destroy all
of her ideological enemies along the way
and in just a couple of weeks she's been
outed as you know as a complete
and a fraud she proved that she's
incapable of answering extremely basic
questions in Congress she also
demonstrated that she's incapable of
writing anything without ripping off
dozens of other papers now given all
this the cognitive dissonance for the
Dei crowd has to be overwhelming right
now I mean after all one of their
holiest figures in their entire cult has
just crashed and burned she's provided
irrefutable evidence that Dei rewards
mediocrity and destroys every
institution that Embraces it and that's
difficult for these people to accept as
you can imagine and that's why in the
wake of claudian Gay's resignation as
president of Harvard there hasn't really
been a debate over the merits of Dei or
anything approaching a reasonable
conversation because the word debate
suggests that two sides are presenting
their arguments in a real and rational
you know a clear and rational way but in
this case what's happening is that the
anti- Dei side is making coherent
arguments while the pro Dei faction can
do nothing but perform and posture and
vomit its emotions all over the place
they're actually a lot less respectable
and coherent than even the flat earthers
because at least the flat earther
opponents have arguments as flimsy as
those arguments may be but that's still
more than can be said for the Dei
Defenders now the spectacle that aired
on CNN over the weekend perfectly
captures this Dynamic it features two
Dei Advocates one of them named Lulu
Garcia Navaro and then another one named
Cara swisser and they're speaking with
two uh male counterparts who are
actually sayane there's rean Salam and
Jonah Goldberg now in this debate
Goldberg and Salam explain why Dei is a
scam used to smuggle leftist ideology
under the guise of diversity uh the
women on the other side of the
discussion can only scowl and huff and
repeatedly declare how infuriated they
are by it Lulu Garcia Navaro also
interrupts constantly while demanding
that the two men on the other side of of
the uh debate stop interrupting her
which they never did so play just a a
portion of this tire fire which aired on
National Television but before we get to
the the really um disastrous part for
the pro Dei side first here's Salam
making the the reasonable case against
the you need to hear this first to fully
appreciate the contrast um so here it is
watch has in effect the country moved on
from the so-called racial Reckoning we
were all talking about after the murder
of George Floyd I think there is a broad
sense that that racial Reckoning
involved smuggling in certain really
contentious ID ological ideas that
weren't ultimately about diversity but
rather were about imposing ideological
uniformity when you're looking at Dei
bureaucracies what really is noxious
about them is that they actually don't
respect all sorts of diversity including
Viewpoint diversity including the fact
that look in some cases you have groups
that are over represented and that can
be okay you know the point that JD Vance
was making about the Dallas Mavericks is
that it can be good and healthy and
reasonable in some domains to have
repesent you can say it's ridiculous you
can make that ass but fundamentally the
fact that you know I am one second
generation Asian-American on a panel at
four I am massively massively
overrepresented but I think it's
reasonable to say that you're going to
judge people based on their
merits now okay put aside the inaccurate
assertion from Chris Wallace that George
Floyd was murdered uh the rest of that
clip is logical level-headed perfectly
coherent
now let's see if things remain on that
level once the other side starts
interjecting let's watch when you're
looking at organizations that count that
matter performance organiz excuse me
excuse me excuse me this is the burden
and I can't tell you how infuriating I
find it this is the burden that always
comes with representation the idea is
that because you are a person of color
suddenly um it is you are only there
because it is some no bless obl it is
because some white guilt put you there
because there was some Dei initiative
and you can't win either either way you
look at it I mean what infuriates me is
you look at the whole claing gay thing
and and everyone's talking about
Dei this woman cannot win or lose
either if she is there let me finish let
me let me let me finish if she's there
it's because of Dei that they put her
there because she's black if she loses
and they kick her out it's because she
actually was never good enough to be
there in the beginning and she was you
can't win in this situation and it is
and it is infuriating as a person of
color to constantly have this cudgel put
on our I get the argument you can't win
but you also can't have it both ways you
can't celebrate and tout that someone
was hired and it's a wonderful thing to
expand diversity and Harvard went Full
Tilt talking about how great it was to
hire the first black woman and then say
all of a sudden the first black person
it wasn't even the first black woman the
first black person I don't care the
point is is that she got caught
obviously plagiarizing and that is the
those are the facts that you know
there's this massive an ideological very
well funded the motives of the attack
don't change the fact that you
plagiarized and and where I disagree
with you cara is when you say when
somebody fails who's white and and who's
a man let me finish when some fails yes
when someone nobody in fact there's
books written about this fail and then
come back um you know look look at pivot
exactly
pivot okay so there's a lot of
incoherence in in that too she she was
struggling to figure out what her Point
even was well you can't you can't win
you can't win or lose I mean you can't
you can't lose what no you can't win
what what can't you do she and then she
says that well if she's if she's hired
it's only because she's black because of
diversity and then if she gets fired
it's only because she's a plagiarist
well yeah I mean that's pretty much how
it works with Dei so that's the funny
thing is that if it sets up a no- win
scenar scario which by the way this this
didn't have to be a no- win scenario for
claudian gay if she wasn't a plagiarist
then she'd still have the job and that
but um if it does set up a no wi
scenario it's it's it is Dei setting up
that no wi scenario when you when you
start hiring people because she didn't
really make the point well but you could
make the point although it's an anti-di
point that when you hire people based on
their race and you tout uh they're
hiring because of the diversity and
inclusion then you have automatically
um created this sort of Aura of
Suspicion around this person that
they're not cut out for the job because
if they were cut out for the job then
you wouldn't need to say anything about
the diversity you would just hire them
based on the merits if you don't hire
based on the merits then people suspect
that oh this person doesn't have the
merits for the job as we head towards a
presidential election in November
there's one thing you can be sure of
2024 will be a tumultuous year how will
your hard-earned savings fair you will
already see the impacts of inflation at
the pump and the the grocery store the
dollar continues to lose buying power
faster than wages can increase how are
you protecting your savings you got to
consider diversifying with gold from the
Birch gold group for decades gold has
been the choice of investors and central
banks to hedge against inflation if you
have an IRA of 401k from a previous
employer it's just Gathering dust call
Birch gold and they will help you
convert it into an IRA in Gold you're
not going to pay a penny out of pocket
they'll simply convert that 401k into
physical gold which unlike digital
currency cannot be tampered with just
Tex Walsh to 9898 98 and Birch gold will
send you a free kid on gold with an A+
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of satisfied customers and the
exclusive gold company of the daily wire
for the past 7even years you could trust
Birch gold to text Walsh to 98 9898 to
claim your free info kit that's Walsh to
98 9898 and secure your savings now so
again if there's a if it if it's a lose
lose scenario it is one that Dei sets up
but the whole segment goes on like this
the women just keep shouting about how
horrible it is to assume that Claudine
gay was a Dei hire even though Harvard's
policy for Generations now has been to
elevate mediocre candidates on the basis
of their skin color and then when it's
pointed out the Claud and gay plagiarize
more than half of her academic writings
the response is to you know just attack
the motivations of the people who
uncovered the
plagiarism but but even if that's true
that the people were politically
motivated un covering it's still
plagiarism and what is her response to
that when Jonah Goldberg points out that
yeah well whatever the motivations were
she still plagiarized she says oh come
on
oh come on yeah but yeah but still come
on they have no response but just to
Screech incoherently and as with so many
other debates on so many other issues if
you know nothing about the issue and you
saw this discussion right you would
immediately know that the women on the
left are full of crap without knowing
anything else because you can tell they
bring nothing but their emotions to the
table all they have is their indignation
and their
feelings if you ask them for evidence to
prove their assertion they'll say
something about books that have been
written about this and this is why these
people get in trouble for plagiarism so
often by the way they don't know how to
provide citations they just say books
well where did you get that uh books I
got it from books right you know there's
books about it you know I if you read
their their one of their papers and
there's a little citation Mark and you
go down to the footnotes you know you
look for where it is it just says
books and again all this would be clear
to any Observer had no background
knowledge about the subject if you do
have background knowledge then it's even
more obvious that these women on the
left are full of crap now on this issue
like so many others the
left uh has no intellectual leg to stand
on if there was any sort of substantive
argument to be made for Dei they would
make it they would produce evidence for
example that institutions become more
effective as they become more diverse
and inclusive they wouldn't just assert
this as a fact as they always do they
would show it but they can't instead
they simply insist that their position
must be true and even if it isn't true
only a bigot would point that out
because after all pointing things out
noticing things is the cardinal sin on
the left that appears to be their entire
argument when it comes to the entire
claudian gay controversy you know they
won't try to claim that gay didn't
plagiarize it's clear that she did
repeatedly so instead they appear to be
arguing that it was our responsibility
to not notice the plagiarism or to
ignore it once we did notice it because
she's a black woman now this is the
total intellectual bankruptcy that you
find on the left and since the left
controls all of our powerful
institutions this intellectual
bankruptcy lies at the core of all of
them now this is the larger problem uh
underlying the Claudine gay debacle you
know the real problem with Claudine
Gay's plagiarized papers isn't that they
were plagiarized it's the fact that even
if they were original thoughts they were
still vapid and dumb and pointless
thoughts you know it used to be that
Harvard presidents conducted original
research on important topics like you
know
biochemistry but now they write useless
garbage for a non-existent audience
solely to advance themselves and this is
the part of the whole claing gay story
that you don't hear much about but it's
far more important actually than the
fact that she lifted several paragraphs
from other authors it turns out that
even if she hadn't plagiarized a word of
her academic writings claudian gay would
still be a total fraud
so first of all let's just look at the
topics of all of her Publications okay
every single one of them is about black
people or equity in some fashion and
that's not an exaggeration that's like
the only thing she wrote about before
she got this job that was claudian Gay's
Obsession her papers have titles like
the effect of black congressional
representation on political
participation and the impact of gender
and race on the politics of black women
and the effect of economic disparity on
lack attitudes towards
Latinos so this is what passes for
research on diversity you know it's it's
it's the least uh diverse resume you can
possibly
imagine every it's all the same subject
it's like paging through a random author
bio on salon.com
you know with with a sole exclusive
focus on black issues Claud and gay for
that reason alone shouldn't have been in
the running for any job anywhere in
Academia but perhaps maybe historically
black college like what was she doing
running Harvard in the F the only thing
she cares about are are black issues
it's the only thing she's ever written
about talked about the only thing she
even pretends to care
about but even for historically black
college she would still be totally
unqualified now to be fair to claudian
gay in and of
itself maybe you could argue that this
resume isn't necessarily disqualifying
if Claudine gay had been writing truly
groundbreaking stuff about gender and
race and the politics of black women or
whatever then maybe you might be
inclined to give her a pass on this
singular Obsession that she has on skin
color I mean if she was actually saying
something useful or interesting or
unique or insightful about it then uh
then okay but the deeper you dig the
worse it gets it turns out that claudian
gay wasn't just a race obsessed grifter
who plagiarized whole paragraphs every
now and then in fact the data behind
claudian Gay's papers the information
she was passing off as new and important
was garbage which again is a is a really
a much bigger deal than plagiarism as
big a deal as plagiarism is so let's
zero in on uh one of the papers I
mentioned a few seconds ago it's called
the effect of black congressional
representation on political
participation this paper was published
in the American Political Science review
all the way back in 2001 and it's an
important paper because it's one of the
handful of Publications that somehow got
claudene gay tenure at Stanford
University before she moved on to
Harvard and the basic idea of this paper
is that when black people get elected to
congress they make white people want to
vote less and somehow this thesis made
sense to Claudine gay and everyone who
peer-reviewed this document and to that
end the paper contains all kinds of
tables which point to data that
supposedly proves this point that whites
just hate voting when black people are
on the ballot and that's the kind of
discovery that would confirm that white
supremacy is real and white people are
bad and and uh so that's the idea anyway
so of course both Stanford and Harvard
loved it and of course it was too good
for them to check they just they loved
the conclusion so they didn't bother to
check whether the data was any
good now the problem is that uh a few
decades later a researcher named
Jonathan poison decided to look into the
claim anyway and he found that claudian
Gay's data contradicts itself at one
point Gay's data tables show that
Missouri Congressman Bill Clay's
presence on the ballot didn't have much
impact on voter turnout but elsewhere
gays tables show that bill clay had a
very significant effect on voter turnout
close to a 17% reduction in turnout in
fact now put aside the fact that it's
absurd to claim that bill clay simply
because he's black would would make
white voters want to stay home on
Election Day the question remains why do
Claudine Gay's tables contradict
themselves now there's no clear answer
to that question palisin couldn't come
up with an explanation Claudine gay
certainly hasn't offered one herself and
here's the really incriminating detail
every time researchers have tried to
look into this gay refused to provide
the underlying data that she used to
generate the tables in her papers in
2002 two professors Michael Heron of
Dartmouth and Kenneth shots of Stanford
presented a paper that effectively
debunked Gay's entire methodology and
they included included this footnote
quote we were however unable to
scrutinize Gay's results because she
would not release her data set to us
that's pretty incriminating but but
here's the really amazing thing that
footnote was removed from the final
version of their paper if you try to
find and download the paper online today
you're not going to find any mention of
claudian gay because it's been scrubbed
completely and instead if you find the
paper you'll find that Heron and shot
debunk a hypothetical methodology
without using Claudine Gay's name at all
it's almost like someone wanted to
protect her for some reason
but writing for Jordan shatel uh
scatchell's substack Chris brune got his
hands on the first version of Heron and
shot's takedown and you know the one
that that hasn't been censored or
redacted in any way and the full
uncensored footnote calls Gay's
conclusions quote logically inconsistent
it repeat repeatedly calls out Claudine
gay by name and it includes a lot of
technical details which no one including
claudi and gay has refuted now
now the point is that this is a far
bigger Scandal than claudian gay lifting
some paragraphs here and there as bad as
that is the fact is that her ideas and
the data underlying those ideas were
useless and fraudulent and apparently
just like made up her Publications were
race-based screeds that were only ever
cited by a handful of academics and
those handful of academics very quickly
proved that they were complete garbage
and yet somehow became president of
Harvard and documents criticizing the
substance of her quote unquote
scholarship were scrubbed and even now
she's still making around $900,000 a
year as a
professor this is the state of Harvard
University and American Academia in
general and this is the key Point yes
our intellectual Elites are often
thieves and
plagiarist you know that certainly
matters but what matters more is that
they are just as intellectually bankrupt
as they are more morally bankrupt they
are charlatans at every
level and their power and influence is
crumbling by the day and based on their
panic over the past few weeks we could
be pretty sure that they're aware of it
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there